[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome welcome welcome back to this
this week's edition
of bonehead of the week
how was your how was your christmas
christmas vacation your holiday holiday
weekend gabe uh not too bad i'm still
still technically on it oh okay yeah
that's why that's why we have a
different background yeah different
background not a green screen just
different setting all together
that is what's going on do you look like
you're in a bunker though
uh i do i'm i'm bunkered down here in
another part of california oh okay uh
yeah yeah it has been raining a lot out
here so i've been pretty much stuck
inside the whole time i've uh
see
well you know that happens that happens
yes i guess
so we had bone end of the week and and
we're gonna try to keep it the 30
minutes here so we're going to try to
get right into this we had these three
these three boneheads this week
but boy has the news the news moves
since we started this process with these
boneheads
yeah uh uh
i mean i feel like that every week you
know we'll be like oh great here are the
people that we throw out there and then
at the same time um
within a day two days or less they're
like boom out of the news and it's
someone new you know right well and it
feels like it feels like almost that
they're uh
that the only the only ones we can
really count on here is like lauren
lauren beaubert yeah lauren marger
taylor green for sure uh you know
there's some other people that's kind of
like
seep in
um
but those are those are the those are
the
the main states well you know i think i
think next week since we're coming to
the new year and we're gonna do a bone
end next week for the beginning here
maybe we'll do 2021's bonehead of the
year bonehead of the week our bone end
of the week bonehead of the year edition
i guess yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that
that would be the right way so so this
week's poll is not going to necessarily
be this week's boneheads it's gonna be
20 20 ones yeah it's going to be the
right uh re-encompassing uh
yeah and it it really is hard to pick
three out of 20 21 though it is
always hard to pick three uh i mean even
when we were batting around ideas for
what the end of the year version was
going to be i think we threw out like
ten you know and we're like no no we
need three right um
and we couldn't even
yeah it's it's it's a lot yeah it's it
is it is always a lot
a lot of boneheads a lot of [ __ ]
boneheads but but i think i i think we
will be able to establish three
boneheads um for you guys to vote on
we'll probably put that up um later on
this evening or maybe tomorrow uh once
we get once we figure out exactly who
the bonehead of the week bonehead of the
year edition is
right for us to do next weekend so stay
tuned for that but let's get into the
bone ends here let's go straight for
roger stone
um you know we have let me let me share
a screen here we have uh
roger stone came in at like 3.8 which is
really surprising
yeah you know what i mean yeah he came
he came in and did last but i think
again it's because of like
i don't know i guess compared to
everything else going on he wasn't a big
time uh mover but
he
i don't know i mean like you know plead
the fifth so
well right let's let's let's go to roger
stone here because i have i have a uh
i have a video that i want to show
here with roger stone and the reason why
well we could play this crazy video
where he's acting crazy in a deposition
which i think everyone's seen that but
there is a video that brian um go ahead
what what no i just saw that guy that
was in a speedo for a moment oh a guy
nsfw yeah i thought that was roger stone
for a moment just like kind of yeah
there we go yeah wow you know
we'll scroll on down gabe's
gabe's getting a little you know you
you've done this uh where you've you've
got matt gatz and a couple other
people um i'm trying to find this
jeez i put him in very compromising
positions that's for sure yeah well you
know okay here's here's the tweet i
wanted to find uh this is this is brian
here um he's get
this video here let's let's
and basically it's someone in particular
talking about
pleading the fifth
fifth
bob the mob takes different
if you're innocent why are you taking
the fifth yeah i know i know
horrible yeah horrible the mob takes
effect they do if you're innocent why
are you taking this
yeah the mob takes [ __ ]
sounds like projection i don't know yeah
well so so we all know um the one reason
why we put roger stone
on this uh week's bonus of the week is
because he went to the january 6th
select committee and bled the fifth
like to all the questions
i mean is there any more other than i
mean he is a [ __ ] bonehead in general
but is there any more reason we need to
continue with roger stone no i mean
he'll come back in the news i'm sure but
uh for this week
yeah he's [ __ ] roger stone yeah i'm sure
he'll be the bonehead coming up in the
in the coming months yeah and then we
had sarah palin here which i don't even
know who who is sarah palin who is this
um
you betcha
because we i i i really so i think
there's one video here that i want to uh
that i wanna that i want to play here is
it the one where she can see covet from
her house well you know
it does happen yeah you can see coven
this is that yeah of course
a lot of this bone end of the week stuff
um with our dishonorable mention this
week too turns out that turning points
usa has uncovered a lot of this garbage
and the charlie kirk circle jerk as i
can say um the let's go brandon crowd
the the written house rules
[ __ ] um but ron posted this and
says sarah palin showed up at phoenix
this morning to tell the crowd it will
be over my dead body that she gets
vaccinated that means she's vaccinated
um then she encourages others to stiffen
their spines and fight back because
she's vaccinated there is an empowerment
in the group like this where we can kind
of feed off each other
let's just let's listen to what this
bonehead had to say
and i will
it'll be over my dead body that i'll
have to yeah it will be over you're dead
yeah all right
again i'm betting she's vaccinated what
are you yeah and if she's not and and if
she's not either way the grim reaper's
in the corner just going like this like
he's just waiting
like this like you don't want to get
vaccinated okay fantastic i mean nothing
like the grin reaper that's a big notch
on his belt right
yeah that's a big one i mean i know that
he's got some other ones planned but you
know if he's like hey listen you do the
job quicker greater because that's
that's well i mean he's got a lot of
planning to do with this with this
omicron this i call it the [ __ ] variant
rolling around yeah that's that's that's
what they're setting all this stuff up
for is uh you know because trump did his
little candace owens thing um
well
so
cause now because now candace owens i
just saw something she was talking about
uh ingesting silver
and there's another thing about how
wait wait wait wait is this like the
eating dirt thing
yeah let me see if i can find it really
quick jesus christ is eating silver
let's listen while you're looking for
that let's listen to what this other
band
well governor some people say though i
might lose my job
i might get kicked out of school you are
you're gonna lose okay i know and um
okay yeah go ahead uh collodial silver
collodion silver yeah yeah so uh
so is it called coo like the last one
what are they called no no no no no
they don't they don't have they know i
have a [ __ ] no this one is collodial
silver and real candace owens is on
instagram and real candace owens replied
with i take a teaspoon a day
more when i'm sick
it's like you're it's like it's like
it's like self munch hounds and syndrome
you know okay so here's the thing
they could go
get a shot and it takes like i don't
know you know maybe 15 15-minute drive
to a pharmacy to get it maybe you got to
wait 30 minutes to get the thing
and then you're done you don't have to
you don't have to eat dirt you don't
have to take silver you don't have to
take a borax bath you don't have to take
the horse pace i mean there is a lot
like they're taking
like the [ __ ] rogan regiment right
like they're constantly adding stuff and
it's like getting exhausting like how
much [ __ ] they actually have to do yeah
going for me but you're not getting go
for free they're going to like the ends
of the earth to find an alternative
solution literally literally yeah
to avoid taking the vaccine and now
merck has the covet pills and i'm now
curious like if they'll even take those
right which by the way i can anticipate
a markup because
you know the same company that made your
ivermectin big pharma is probably now
gonna price gouge you for these merc
pills because you don't want to take the
vaccine that was subsidized by the
government and free for you to get
meanwhile you're willing to pay big
pharma for all of these other
or
pharmaceutical or holistic regime i'm
gonna start digging holes in the yard to
dig up i don't know i mean maybe maybe
we should maybe we should put like
earthworms that are that have i feel
like
maybe they'll feel
business of selling
supplements because that absolutely that
whole market isn't regulated by the fda
so i could sell whatever i wanted and i
can call it a covered cure or at least a
covet treatment
you know let's treat your symptoms to
treat your symptoms it would you like
treat yourself
there's a brand name treat yourself
speaking of brand speaking of brand
names you know uh we've got we've got
these boneheads and we've got our winter
joe mansion but let's go to the
dishonorable mention we do a
dishonorable mention every week and we
really want to talk about this [ __ ]
bonehead uh because
there's a lot of stuff to unpack about
this [ __ ] in such a short period of
time and i'm glad that we can give jared
schmuck here his his five minutes of
fame or ten minute whatever long we're
gonna talk about this [ __ ] idiot here
yeah um but apparently he went on he
went on steve bannon's trader tv right
to clear up any kind of um
mess that he may have caused yeah right
is that is that is that what is that
what's going on here yeah and to preface
the video before we go into it the the
big deal that's going on here is that he
did an interview with the oregon live so
everyone's like oh like for i guess for
context he he called in on the christmas
live stream
and at the end of the call after having
a very nice conversation and was super
cordial with president obama one way for
me to like man i got a chance right and
he uh he said let's go brandon and
everyone's getting him [ __ ] because it's
like oh you know it was you didn't have
to do that right that's that's the [ __ ]
that that's just unnecessary right and
so then everyone's like oh people are
doxxing him and it's like no
he willingly chose to post that stuff
online and then he willingly chose to
give an interview with oregon live
or didn't his
she like posted something on instagram
who he was and all that kind of yeah she
posted on instagram and says my husband
may or like may have just told the
president or may have just said to the
president let's go brandon and then he
posted on youtube the video of him on
the call
right that's how we have the video of it
right exactly and then there's the part
of like okay he gave an interview with
the oregon
newspaperorgonlive.com i think is what
it is and in there he's like oh i don't
have any resentment towards the
president or i'd rather i just have them
against the policies i'm
this is the important one i am not a
trumper
always a red flag
whenever someone goes whenever someone's
i'm not a trumper and then there's like
a butt or like an ellipses instant red
flag instant red flag well i mean i mean
you've got this in your in your comments
right like in your comment thread you go
down like well i don't i don't support
trump i don't support any party and then
you go to their page and it's like
trumper after trump or after trump or
i've had a ton of comments from the
video that i made about this
uh where people were like
um you made a video you made a video
about this no she really don't yeah well
if we're lucky people can see it
uh but in the video
in the comments of the video people were
like i'm not political but or like i
uh i have no political take on this yeah
but it seems like people are triggered
by let's go brandon it's like no one is
triggered by this that's not what we're
taught why do they think it pisses us
off why because they're going to make an
example of this they're like oh well you
brought it up so clearly you're
triggered and it's like but that's not
what yeah we're bringing it up because
you sound dumb you should just say [ __ ]
joe biden like we said [ __ ] trump i yeah
i [ __ ] trump [ __ ] him [ __ ] him i had
some person
i hit some troll the other day i was
trying to get me we're like uh they're
like oh it was a screenshot of a graphic
i made of trump where it was like i put
his face on the joker and it was a pile
of money and it was all the problems
from his presidency and i used the
hashtag fdt right [ __ ] donald trump
right and
uh he was like oh is this you censoring
yourself what a [ __ ] flaming liberal
hippocratic hypocrite and i go
and i responded i was like oh a hashtag
uh dude [ __ ] joe biden [ __ ] donald trump
i don't give a [ __ ] right and then he
wrote a comment and then deleted it and
then i
in that moment i had it so it was like
oh you know he wrote this whole thing
about [ __ ] joe biden and then he deleted
it and i was like oh bro is this you
censoring yourself right now right like
uh but yeah i've got tons of trolls
about this dumb [ __ ] where they're like
oh you're so triggered i'm like no one
is triggered we're just
telling you how it's done it's really
stupid number one
if joe biden is brandon like if he is
brandon if that's the thing in it yeah
brandon
from his basement sorry
well and the other thing is it's let's
go bri of course i have the thanks
brandon thing like thank you brandon and
i do the headline thing because it's
like really you're it doesn't make any
sense just say [ __ ] joe biden but i know
why they're doing it it's all code talk
it's it's another it's another trope um
that that they like to trot out you know
like uh back the blue or blue lives
matter you know it means means
we're against we're against black people
that's what it means it's not four cops
again it's not for joe biden it's
we hate libtards right that's why they
get so excited when they say it because
they're owning the libs or whatever and
they get to satan church they think
that's funny they think that's cool it's
just funny because like oh it's a good
it's like an inside joke and it's like
well if everyone knows the joke and it's
not a good joke because it's just
it's like the person who peaked in high
school joke right right and it's like
if it's not good and that's what we're
talking about we're not talking like you
could just say [ __ ] joe biden like
you're you're just saying [ __ ] joe biden
you're the people who are aren't you and
politically correct just say [ __ ]
stop cancel culturing yourself say [ __ ]
joe biden i i [ __ ] you but i you know
what i said [ __ ] joe biden um was the
last week when they were
they're waffling back and forth ready to
extend
right relief on the on the student debt
yeah like [ __ ] joe biden [ __ ] yeah they
need to [ __ ] get this [ __ ] i'll
criticize where they need to be
criticized
i'm not i'm not tied to joe biden it's
not a thing that i worship he's not a
god of mine right exactly and that's the
thing it's like that their side is like
you gotta accept everything or nothing
and if you're nothing then you're the
enemy and it's like no dude you can
accept some parts of someone just like
in a relationship with someone they're
like oh there are you know some things
that we work on and other things that i
love about you right but at the same
time it's like uh i'm not going to be in
there you want to work on your
relationship with trump is that what
you're saying or joe biden which one or
joe biden do you actually want to [ __ ]
joe biden because it's something clear
they say they say [ __ ] joe biden and
it's like they're like
so so speaking speaking of people who
worship people who aren't trumpers
right ron posted this video of this joe
schmuck or schmeck is it schmeck or
schmuck it's magma
okay so joe schmeagma here he's on steve
bannon's trader tv let's listen to this
clip and let's determine if this guy's a
trumper or not i think and and i mean
it's
it was one way for me to like man i got
a chance right now to to voice my
disapproval of yeah of this man and his
administration so many better ways to
dish your
divorce let's go brandon and
what is joe biden's like yeah let's
let's go
i'm i'm winning but i love how i love
how it's like
it's like this is my opportunity to
express my disapproval and it's like you
you set a tagline you didn't specify
like i have a problem with uh that's
because they don't right exactly they're
like well i don't i have a problem with
this or this loan relief or this
whatever or this policy it's like let's
go brandon it's like all bad
right it's we're again we're in the
intersection of wrestlemania real life
so it's i'm going to root for the bad
guy because i like the heel right but
also the ability or the inability to
have an actual discussion and say i am
it's like you know let's use our
question what is that
let's use our words children
i
i feel
i feel unhappy because why and then
they're like let's go brandon and it's
like just say what you don't what you're
not happy with say what you want to work
on say what they should fix and and
focus on not let's go brandon which is
like that's just like yelling into the
room and then leaving and then thinking
that someone knows what the [ __ ] you're
going right but that would require them
to actually know what's going on in
government and politics
and
what is that what is that what is that
what is that disa you're you're john q
public what is that what is that
disapproval
for us
yeah yeah i mean for me let's go brandon
public is and i've said it in other
articles i am a christian man oh you are
for me it's god first and foremost i
don't follow any one man blindly um some
of the media has run with that and said
i don't support donald trump that's
absolutely false donald trump is my
president and he should still be
president right now a trump the election
was 100 stolen um so i just want to make
that oh that's it
but uh that's really gross so he's not a
trumper he's wearing a
great again
not a trumper wearing a maga hat he
doesn't follow someone blindly he's a
christian as they all are well they are
yeah and then he says
i'm a i'm a i think in the in the
article he did for the oregon life he
said
i
uh i'm not simple-minded
i am a free-thinking american and a
follower of jesus christ sure and it's
like okay and then other and then
additionally he goes i'm not a trumper
to which you're like you
are a walking
contradiction and you just proved
yourself that you were he's your
president it was stolen and you voted
for trump and it's like i don't want to
trumper i don't want to pull up the uh
the video again but here is the picture
that you pulled from the video for the
bone end of the week right and he's
clearly wearing make america great again
hat now we talked about this a little
bit before
beforehand is uh we were talking about
before we came on the area about how the
candace owens donald trump thing is
really starting to create cracks here
and i actually think i actually think
that what trump the trump cult wants to
do is separate
make america great again in the manga
movement away from trump like yeah like
he's saying you know he's saying all the
trumpy things because i believe that
it's starting to get to where the
realization that trump's going to be in
a lot of trouble here not just
politically
but possibly criminally and legally
is that they're going to want to cut him
off like he's going to be a cancer that
they're going to get off i mean she
already said america she already said in
the follow-up where she was like
she was like in the little like uh
closet having the little like it's like
so trump um he's older he's not really
tech savvy like she's throwing him under
the bus and basically you talking about
candace owens after the interview yeah
yeah where she's doing she's doing like
her damage control because everyone's
like oh you know because i guess uh
supposedly so this is after she posted
it yeah after she did the interview
right after trump it was like no no take
the vaccine because i just want to point
out is this before she posted the video
or after she posted the video of this
crazy where they're back and forth yeah
yeah this was after
she posted it she posted this little
like hey everyone uh just so you know
like she's i know but i'm saying
what i'm saying is when in the timeline
so she posted the interview to online
and then everything everyone's like oh
my god this is not the way it needs to
be and then she tried to do clean up
right or did she do clean up before she
posted it
i saw the video after from what i
understand it was after the fact so she
posted the interview online
uh unless you find something different
uh she posted the interview online it
got a bunch of backlash there were
rumors or something that was spreading
about her donors kind of backing away
because of the message that he had sent
on her show
and she's like trying she's like oh no
well people are don't want to get the
vaccine and then trump also keep in mind
is so and i even said this online is so
narcissistic and so egotistical that he
cannot let anyone else take credit for
the vaccine right
fine do it i don't even care at this
point just like take credit so that
other people do it and if he converted
some people awesome oh yeah but
i think that's the crack though don't
you think exactly that's exactly what's
happening and then candace owens goes on
her phone in a little room and she's
like so everyone uh donald trump is
older like he's not really with it and
technology stuff which is like she's
literally telling everyone that this guy
is incompetent don't listen
against him and she's like don't listen
to him he doesn't have all the facts
like he doesn't really account for all
the studies of all these other people
who have died or gotten things and it's
like those aren't even peer-reviewed
studies and you've got to send me this
video later yeah i will try to find it
and they have not verified the fact that
uh uh that any of the results of anyone
who has had
negative effects like death or whatever
she's quoting
has actually been from the vaccine
itself they're all just like well the
guy took the vaccine
it's like joe rogan when he was like i
know a guy who took the vaccine and
almost stroked out like what the like
that's not even true okay yeah anyway so
she's doing damage calling she's she's
throwing throwing him on the bus but the
point here is is that they're working
really hard because we see this this
separation start to happen right and
what i mean separation is um obviously
the maga world is either gonna have to
decide to support trump or not support
trump at some point here
because you know they're being torn
apart right and we always knew we always
knew these fascists were gonna eat each
other you know they were gonna continue
to eat each other this is the video of
candace owens by the way okay if we get
to that we'll go back but i want to play
a video real quick while i'm talking
about this
uh some that someone else did here um
i'm not sure who it was and i think this
is they met him and uh this schmuck
schmeck character schmeckums
in the woods
came in no i'm all over the news man why
what's your name schmeck schmuck schmeck
uh smegma schmeck okay so what's wrong
i'm being attacked for utilizing my
freedom of speech why well my kids and i
were talking to president biden and his
wife on a christmas day live stream and
i said let's go brandon what f joe biden
huh
you wanna joe biden no it's a vulgar dig
at biden i'm just playing with you man
we all know what it means code word yeah
it's a pretty lame code word that
triggers no one look man i'm not
simple-minded okay i'm a free-thinking
american and a follower of christ but as
a follower of christ you should love thy
neighbor i'm the victim here so let me
get this straight you and your children
were having a very nice conversation
with president biden and his wife yeah
and then you said let's go brandon which
you know means joe biden it was funny my
wife put it on instagram and i put it on
youtube and then you chose to post it
online for everyone to see but now
you're the victim it's not fair okay i'm
the victim
okay
okay so how's your house how's schmeck's
hands feeling
number one uh
i i they feel i from what i understand
he's about he's gonna sue the tree okay
so uh he feels pretty hurt you know okay
well you know it happens yeah but this
this goes back to this christian thing
and really honestly the the the other
thing that uh i think is important here
to remember is that at this turning
points usa event
uh there's don donald trump jr is
starting to come out this video where
he's basically saying all that christian
stuff that never got us anywhere we knew
abandoned that which it's like i hate to
tell donald trump jr this
but these [ __ ] evangelical christian
conservative maga trump humping q and
uncle they never really believed that
[ __ ] oh no no no it was just it's just
an umbrella label for a group of people
that are able to
uh excuse their behavior
um
by
by saying that it was for religious or
it's what christ would have done or what
have you even though a lot of it is um
contradictory or hypocritical or just uh
you know yeah well
hypocritical christians now
no
religion baby it's it's the downfall of
the civilization we're not gonna i want
to play this candace owens video but we
really don't have enough time i'd hate
to i hate to break it to you gabe but
i'm gonna go i'm gonna definitely go
look at this
just know that she is uh calling him
incompetent and throwing him under the
bus to save her own ass
okay well the the thing i want to get to
here though is i want to get to our
winner because we do have we do have a
winner this week even though um and a
winner is always a loser
well and and and bonehead of the week
context that is we have we have senator
joe manchin a lot of people point out
that his mansion it sounds like
manchester mansion
i am manchester manchin mansion mansion
man senator joe manchin lives in a
mansion yeah but has a man chin okay
yeah that makes sense yeah that makes
sense and we see the kind of man
chin
here yeah possibly yeah you know okay
well let's let's give him his due let's
play his his race here
[Applause]
[Music]
well of course of course i think we
posted the the bone end of the week like
the day
after he was like [ __ ] you i'm not i'm
not [ __ ] voting for
the i caught the big bird bill but the
better act yeah exactly and and the
reason why is because of the child tax
credit that's
what's funny about this whole thing
is that joe manchin
makes cause i think he's actually lying
he's gonna vote for it that's what i
think
i think he actually went on fox news
because to lie that he's not gonna vote
for it and the reason why is because fox
news is where lies go like he went on
fox news to lie to the fox news viewers
to tell the fox news viewers i'm not
gonna vote for it that way when he does
vote for it they still believe that he
didn't because he said it on fox news
so yeah that's my i feel like that's
giving him a lot of credit but who knows
you know i i actually i actually think i
actually have a lot of confidence um in
the president i have a lot of confidence
in his team to get this uh the big bird
bill as i call it past now i i actually
think what joe manchin's trying to do is
not only confuse the fox news viewers of
how he's gonna vote or whatnot but i
also believe what he's doing is trying
to strip out uh parts of the bill
that maybe his donors or some other
people don't want him to vote for in
this bill um if the child tax credit
comes out of the bill he'll be happy um
of course americans will be [ __ ]
pissed including trump humpers all over
the country because right now if they
have children and they're below a
certain income level they're getting the
child tax credit distributed every
single month into their bank accounts or
in their mailbox um which is gonna
really [ __ ] piss them off and it it
seems that the child tax credit is
really popular in a very impoverished
state like west virginia which joe
manchin just happens to be the senator
of so my view of it is is that joe
manchin is gonna vote for this rather
has a child tax credit or not i believe
joe manchin was very scared of becoming
irrelevant with the child tax credit and
the reason why is because murkowski
collins and romney could come in and
support a bill that had the child tax
credit some say they wouldn't um but
there's a lot of
there's a lot of behind-the-scenes uh
policy-making here and i believe that
nancy pelosi would have never cut a deal
in the house
um to move this to the senate if she
didn't know joe manchin was gonna vote
for this no matter what even if it took
him to go on fox news completely piss
off all liberals completely make all the
maga crown the fox news crowd go yay woo
hoo he's not gonna vote for it and then
he'd vote for it so i believe there's a
lot of um there's a lot of
washington theatrics that play here um
not just on joe manchin side but on
everyone else's side as well to make
sure this the vote happens the way
that it needs to happen on the floor of
the senate right that's what i think now
a lot of people um don't give joe
manchin enough uh credit here but he is
a dirt bag for for steak whether it's
theatrics or not to stake his claim that
um the thing that he doesn't like about
the bill is that families who have
children with this child tax credit
which by the way is romney's little
thing here
has pulled millions of children out of
poverty that he wants to give them the
big middle finger and say [ __ ] you you
don't you don't get to have that that
that the tax and really honestly what
the thing that pisses me off most about
this child tax credit thing is that
democrats totally missed the boat on
rebranding this thing
back uh when they passed the covet
relief package back in march they should
have called it inflation protection is
what they should have called it um and
joe manchin wouldn't be saying this joe
manchin couldn't go on tv and say
inflation we're going to get rid of that
inflation protection right you know yeah
i that's just my point you go ahead and
you tell me what you think of joe
manchin here before we
i i uh on the opposite end i think that
gives joe manchin a lot of credit now
whether he is trying to be some
puppeteer in the background of going on
fox news and lying about it to mislead
them to rile everyone up to also throw
the white house in the game to be like
all right here are the receipts of what
you promised biden to say i don't know i
think there's a lot of assumptions there
it would be a crazy thing but at the end
of the day it's like i don't know i mean
you could be like what was the point
but i also could be like
like it just seems like a
like a lot of i mean
so what you're saying is i'm wrong i'm
saying you're wrong like i think i think
it gives
yeah yeah i mean it could it could it
could very well be some calculated uh
plan well i mean they always they always
think they're calculating right right
and they always i think i think it was i
i actually think it was calculated uh i
think it was a big miscalculation i
think yeah
well i think so i mean like here's the
thing like it would have been really i
mean
whether he runs again or i mean his
constituents have obviously spoken out
since then to be like
we would love to have this thing passed
right you know even if they're trump
even if they're trump supporters they
want right exactly and i think right now
like you see you see the bump in the
virus happening spikes happening you see
that oh [ __ ] we're you know we're in
winter so this is probably going to get
worse like the economy obviously the
economy has has uh
has that was a 10 10.7 percent increase
uh what did i see the other day in
december you know which is great right
um really goes against uh
let's go brandon thanks
thank you brandon yeah thank you um
genuinely thank you um but
yeah i just i'm just like man it's a lot
of wasted like
politicking that he did
on
on getting it
to be like oh no i'm lying i'm playing
you all especially before i don't think
i don't think it's the lying i'm playing
you all i don't think that's it i think
what it is is the calculation is is that
the calculation was nationally he wanted
to go on fox news and say he wasn't
going to vote for it he picked out the
child tax credit because that's the
thing he hates not he actually hates the
the climate change stuff about it the
most and what i mean by him i mean and
the drug oil industry yeah well yeah but
he can't blame it on that right he can't
blame it on that because it'll get he'll
get accused of it so he goes straight
for the socialism thing socialism you
know which we always have gotten child
tax credits in this country it's just
not quite as much as it is as it is now
and we didn't get it distributed monthly
right that's the only thing that really
changed we got more
there was us as a country's whole got a
bigger child tax credit and got it
distributed monthly as opposed to one
time a year during tax season
but i think joe manchin um his
calculation here isn't to [ __ ] everybody
his calculation is to convince um
certain a group of people that he wasn't
going to vote for joe biden's bill
and then go vote for it that's literally
i think was the calculation
huge miscalculation huge step i mean
like you know you could certainly say
like oh i wasn't going to do it just to
say i didn't do it but then eventually
we'll do it because nothing he's going
to he's going to vote for it
bill that they approve and he signs off
on will be the same bill i don't think
anything's gonna change you know
uh in the bill i don't think anything's
gonna be taken out it's gonna be the
exact same thing and he's gonna vote
back on it and then he'll say yes
but there is a party where i'm like yeah
whatever this calculation that was done
it is a huge miscalculation because
i don't
whether he knew or whether he
anticipated the type of response that he
had
from from not voting on it and and going
on and and
basically blasting to say like i don't
like this or this or this
um
i don't know it's like
well you know what i can say that's what
made him bonehead of the week let's give
him his dude
[Music]
[Music]
so thank you joe manchin congratulations
on being bonehead of the week you earned
it rather it was intentional or a
miscalculation either way rather you
don't vote for the bill you do vote for
the bill you really [ __ ] up your
messaging this week either way and
that's why you won bone out of the week
don't forget to go vote on twitter at
tonymichaelspod
for the bonehead of the week we're gonna
put that probably up today or tomorrow
for the bonehead of the year edition uh
follow at tonymichaelspod follow me
tony michaels and follow gabe i am gabe
sanchez
on the tweety tweets and
tomorrow we're gonna start up the [ __ ]
list roundup again we took a couple days
off but we're gonna start it up again we
had the podcast this week i've got a
special guest gabe is not going to be
joining us he's got the traveling and
stuff like that so i'll be doing the
podcast alone this week loser maybe
you're the bonehead of the year huh
miss the very last podcast of the year i
just figured you know it started with
you in 2021
with you 20.
there you go
it's a whole new ball game that's right
that's right that's right well do don't
forget to join us in 2022 every
wednesday three o'clock central four
o'clock eastern youtube twitter twitch
go subscribe to the youtube channel so
you don't miss any of that
and we'll see you we'll see you tomorrow
and see you next week on bonehead of the
week see ya
[ __ ] em [ __ ] em
[Music]
[Applause]